airless pumps are kind of a lie I really
like them but a lot of people assume
they're way better than a dropper bottle
for really air sensitive ingredients
like a scopic acid or vitamin C but they
aren't airless sounds like they block
out air completely but what it means is
that instead of like in a regular pump
where air replaces the product that you
use there's a disc in the bottom that
slides up and reduces the air on top but
standard airless pumps have a hole gr
from the outside world into the product
open the whole time oxygen molecules are
really tiny and move really fast so that
Gap is huge for oxygen molecules on the
other hand if you have a dropper bottle
it's sealed pretty well if you screw it
tightly yes there is some air inside but
if you do the calculations a completely
air filled bottle only has enough oxygen
in it to react with 1/3 of a mill of 15%
elos scopic acid and that is the
absolute worst case scenario in reality
it's going to have less air inside than
that and not all of that will react with
the vitamin C on the other hand the pump
product is in contact with 21% oxygen in
the air from the outside pretty much the
whole time